very good morning to you Chris Perry
thanks so much for talking to us tell us
a little bit about the work that you're
doing there you're there helping people
getting injured people out as I
understand it but explain exactly what
you're doing
so I'm working with a group of
volunteers who've been volunteering uh
since the annexation of Crimea in 2014
so very experienced some local
volunteers and um basically we get uh
requests to evacuate people from the
most newly liberated villages on the
East
um a few days beforehand from usually
from family who have fled to the West
um saying my mum and dad my grandma or
whoever is in this Village and we think
it's going to be retaken soon can you
please go and get them out they've had
no word from them because of course it's
been occupied by Russia so we go in and
basically as soon into the military in
the previous Village say yeah you're
good to go we then go into the village
which essentially is now the new front
and we just run around bang on doors
trying to find anyone to course
everyone's hiding out in their basements
and eventually we'll find somebody who
then said oh yeah Bob's over there we
then go to his basement
um hopefully try and persuade him with a
video of this relative
um and then they'll come out with us to
uh kind of the local town where we put
them across until with our feds they've
got a warm bed you know shelter finally
for the first time since I think the
most recent Village they've taken by the
Russians on the 3rd of March so they've
been living in basements since then
well yes and give us more on that
reaction that you get from those those
relatives when you first approach them
how are people feeling they must be very
frightened
yeah so um we're very fortunate that we
are working with uh ukrainians but
sometimes when we haven't got a
translator all over with us
um things a lot more difficult because
of course I don't speak language and I'm
just a foreign person saying come with
us come with us in English which they
don't speak so they're very uh skeptical
and quite afraid
um we've had people basically say sorry
we don't want to come with you because
they're terrified we're going to take
you into the woods and shoot them
because they think we could be Russian
because they have no idea what has been
happening in the outside world because
they've just been locked in this little
bubble of this village with no outside
cons no ukrainians there to talk to them
or soldiers or anything so they've just
been sat in their basement for what
seven or eight months with no outside
information so suddenly when a van
appears saying get in the van we're
taking you to safety like would they
believe us normally probably not
yeah so that that is tough and tell us a
little bit more about where you take
them do you take them out of the country
or do you take them to hospitals still
within Ukraine
so uh our group kind of um specializes
in little runs to the the front so we
will basically drive like an hour from
here in Providence to the front line
Villages take them uh basically out to a
nearby town which is uh they've set up
um uh a hospice which is now converted
into sort of refugee Center for these
people who have had to leave all of
their belongings and we get to take we
take them there and then they have um
kind of nurses there who look after them
for a few weeks whilst they kind of like
sort their lives out
and as I understand it you your job as a
running coach in Cheltenham so how are
you finding it there in Ukraine you talk
about going to the front line the new
front line that must be extremely
dangerous how how are you handling it
um
I don't know I think uh maybe I'm a bit
of an odd one but I kind of take each
day as it comes
um sometimes when you see some pretty
terrible things it does stay with you uh
for example seeing kind of uh
the burnt out corpse of uh her mother
who we were evacuating
um it was supposed to be evacuating her
and her daughter but unfortunately the
day before we arrived their houses was
hit so she the daughter very sadly burnt
to death and the mother was she was just
uh she was like a ghost
um so that that does stick with you but
in the moment you know you've got a job
um you've got a you're in a position of
care as soon as you pick these people up
you've got to just get out um and get
away from sort of the artillery or the
drones which is kind of constantly going
off around us so
um because of the intensity in the
moment it's fine but it's kind of when
you get back and you start to like
think oh that was kind of close that was
only 100 meters away from us and that's
when you kind of think okay maybe uh
maybe my luck might run out but it's
worth it to save these people I think
and in the meantime you're trying to
raise money aren't you for for a new
vehicle tell us a bit about that and why
you need it yeah so um in the summer it
was kind of fine going around in the van
because the roads I mean the roads don't
they're not roads they're just like
tractor Trails but it's okay because
it's hard whereas now I mean you might
be able to hear it's trench or rain and
all the tanks going up and down on these
um on these tractor Trails it's just a
quagmire so
um I've been getting stuck quite
recently and with the winter coming with
snow and the ice this van just won't be
able to get to the places anymore
um and as the Russians are pushed back
in this area uh the roads are only going
to deteriorates so we're trying to
fundraise uh fourway four by four so
that we can actually keep the work
through the winter because for these
people the winter is the hardest time
because it's hitting like minus 50 minus
20. um even at the moment it's starting
to go below zero and just us trying to
find these houses we're getting pretty
chilly let alone being sat in the
basement for months and months
okay and you've got to go find me a page
for that haven't you um well Chris Parry
thanks so much for talking to us this
morning good luck with your work and
stay safe thank you thank you very much